the valorant Renaissance is here after
being sick of these same old same old
the community finally has content that
fixes one of the biggest problems the
game has it comes at the perfect time
where we as a community can change the
game forever
[Music]
see all your daily reminder that we have
the score Esports merch available check
it out with a link in the description
below but if you're konosuke takesha I
will personally hand deliver it with a
box of Cinnabon just how you like it
well we are back for another patch video
but this time I would like to offer an
idea a pretty dramatic idea I believe
patch 6.0 is what has fixed valorant
settle down babes I haven't quite
finished yet before we can talk about
what was fixed we have to talk about
what was wrong with valorent in the
first place no game is perfect but
valorent in particular had a couple of
glaring issues that the community kept
bugging right for solutions for players
interlocking agents with no
repercussions or discussion lack of map
diversity when queuing and a supposed
cascading agent lock that never really
happened thanks forever making do a
whole video on that not to mention
Deathmatch being terrible talks to
community members received no punishment
the list goes on the biggest of course
is the chamber meta for those of you
unaware first off count yourself blessed
because you have not suffered the way we
have suffered but in all seriousness for
most of the past year chamber was such a
broken character that he was almost a
guaranteed pick especially at higher
skill levels I will say the game is
quite boring with chamber in The Meta
right now personally I would love to see
other Sentinels make a comeback because
there is no reason to play a Sentinels
right now when chamber exists in the
like there's no reason to play more
traditional sandals because chamber has
the trip for that same purpose but then
he just opts and clearly kills
everything now ten said all of that six
months ago and it wasn't until this past
December that Riot finally took action
against baguette boy and nerfed him to
the point where he is balanced don't
come at me the man is balanced and
situational like literally every other
agent in the game and I will not take
any questions unless you're a konosuke
takashta and then hey I'm open all day
to answer some questions just let me
know when you're free and but this whole
meta went on for so long that Valerie
became a pretty stale game and yeah
Pearl and harbor came out during this
time frame but every single match I
played chamber was most likely gonna be
picked when not a lot of content is
released and your fan base has noticed a
distinct lack of new content and tweaks
and you have this overarching meta that
you can't seem to escape from we're not
having fun and to everyone saying they
release content yeah they released
Harbor Pearl and a bunch of necessary
tweaks but in retrospect with how much
people play Valerian usually it's not a
lot of content decisions were made 2022
that made valorent in the simplest terms
boring same different day stale
unplayable whatever you want to call it
it was almost like the game was still in
its infancy like it had yet to grow up
to sum it all up I will leave it to this
tweet seen a lot of people complaining
about Valor being stale lately Ballin
has been stale for about the last six
months for me personally we need more
people the community asking more of Riot
we need Community Maps replay system
Maps select avoid players and more Valor
needed to be saved from itself and it
all started with chamber with the
chamber Nerf we saw the return of other
agents that had been pushed out of the
meta KJ and Cypher received necessary
Buffs to help bring back our true
Sentinels literally bringing more agent
diversity in fact it has worked so well
than the most recent qualifiers he was
one of the least picked agents speaking
of what happened recently we received a
whole new map Lotus
of my wing
they went together
Guardians and people
oh there's still so much I don't know
Lotus is special because it is in the
second map in Valor in history to have
three bomb sites the other being Haven
which we have had since forever and has
a cool little gimmick that'll let this
next clip show
the map is not only incredibly large in
size it has two rotating doors that can
be activated to let anyone through for a
period of time they are also incredibly
loud like Riot actually please lower the
sound of the doors I cannot take that I
was literally using the doors to cover
rotations B bomb set is a very unique
plant area while all Sites encourage
diverse aggressions and defenses but why
does having a new map matter what does
this fix how will this fix valorence
issue of staleness well despite the fact
this is literally new content for us to
consume we are still as a community
dealing with the aftermath of the
chamber meta we are still thinking of
new Teen comps new ideas and boom a
whole new map comes along to encourage
our thought process basically there's so
much to think about in terms of how the
game could look Lotus encourages us as
players to think about what is possible
and viable in-game that wasn't last year
when I was playing 10 bands this weekend
I had so much fun with creators like
average Jonas who was working on new
lineups for the map and I'm mean across
the map lineups and with split coming
back with some minor treatments if you
will we will have to think about the map
that we have not been able to see or
play competitively for six months and
again it comes at a time where chamber
is no longer a dominant pick we can
reimagine the split comp is this an
optimistic point of view yeah maybe but
I would argue that's the best way to do
things if you are always pessimistic
about your view of games you're gonna be
sheltered in your Viewpoint I think you
should always be looking forward to
what's next and what's exciting 2022 is
full of the same old valerians the most
exciting things we had were a new map
and new agent do you remember that neon
was released in the beginning of 2022
because it certainly seems like longer
ago to me now the game is practically
inviting us to re-envision what is
possible what we thought we knew we
wanted all the answers right away but
I'm excited to play Valerian for the
first time in a very long time to be
honest I was only playing the game to
keep my skills sharp and be still
invested in the community for the sake
of my job I didn't like playing the game
but now I'm in encourage to play and try
new things and the community is ready
for it too and to have the new Valor
Esports starting up at the exact same
time a perfect opportunity for the game
to find new footing and Rhythm you might
disagree with me you might think Liz the
game has always been exciting you just
haven't been trying hard enough or Liz
the game is still going to be the same
old boring game this is no such thing as
a perfect storm and
that's your prerogative now
now all we need is that damn replay
system
okay so uh I posted like the compilation
of just like my kanoski to catch the
bits from last video and I expected
nothing from it and then he said thank
you with like a blushing emoji and I was
like oh
I was like messaging all my friends I
was like he noticed notice me and then a
little bit after that he followed me
back oh my God I'm a 24 year old woman I
was absolutely having a 13 year old
freak out